[Music]
thank you very much Bob good morning as
the new department head of physics I'm
delighted to welcome you to this
celebration of physics at MIT in
connection with the dedication of our
new Green Center for physics physics is
the science of energy matter and their
interactions today we celebrate the
energy and vision of our faculty and
staff especially mark Kastner Bob Jaffe
and Sean Robinson we thank our generous
donors especially Neil and Jane
Pappalardo Virgil eiling's and Jim and
Sylvia Earle we thank Susan Hockfield in
the Institute for bringing the Green
Center project and the pds eye project
around him to completion the efforts and
dedication of many people brought forth
a partial unification of the physics
department that began as a dream about
30 years ago today we also celebrate the
origin of new Mass not the Higgs boson
not yet rather the new infill building
named 6c in MIT parlance and the
transformation of matter in the
surrounding buildings comprising the
Green Center the Green Center now
provides a focal point for many
departmental activities and a home for
about one fourth of our faculty today we
celebrate the increased interactions
especially those among and across our
Theory groups made possible by the new
Green Center for physics this is an
exciting time and place to be a
physicist at this juncture of
departmental history it's appropriate to
survey the broad panorama of MIT physics
our contributions to science our place
in the national and international stages
and our prospects for the future we're
delighted and very fortunate to have
today this morning the reflections of
four distinguished physicists with MIT
connections I'd like to thank them for
coming I'd like to thank our staff led
by Gretchen Pullman for organizing and
running this tremendous enterprise and I
would like to thank each and
one of you for coming and sharing with
us in the celebration of physics and now
I'd like to turn the baton to Professor
dan kleppner recent awardee of the
National Medal of Science who will
introduce our first symposium speaker
thank you
[Applause]
so it's a great pleasure to welcome and
introduce Charlie towns in the physics
community the named towns is synonymous
with a maser and the laser and those
devices have had a transformative effect
on large areas of science and on society
and on my own career because without the
ammonia maser there would not have been
a hydrogen maser and that's what
launched my career many years ago also
he had a transformative effect in
another sense he was the Provost of MIT
when I came here and played a role in my
coming to MIT and he also played a role
in the transformation of MIT because in
those days MIT was known primarily as a
School of Engineering now it's known as
a school of science and engineering and
the emergence of science as a major
feature of the MIT life is due in no
small part to Charlie's influence in
those days since then he has devoted
himself to his love of radio astronomy
and astrophysics but his career has also
been marked by large areas of public
service he was one of the original
officials of the Institute for Defense
analysis he helped us set up Jason's
over the years he has advised the
government on innumerable problems for
which wisdom and technical knowledge
were required so in my mind and the mind
of people to know him that Charlie
Townes is a role model for what's very
best in physics and we're very pleased
that you're here with us today Charlie
[Applause]
I'm absolutely delighted to be back here
at MIT it's been a little over 40 years
since I was here ah
and the place has changed some on the
other hand great memories still with me
I'm invited to participate with you and
celebrating the green Center this is a
very important center and it's kind of
indicative of what MIT is about and what
we hope it will be it is right in the
middle of the campus and bringing
together theorists particle physics
solid-state physics and so on and hoping
hopefully bringing together all the
physics to go now there's an important
aspect of Science and Technology it's
important aspect of MIT mit has been
great in uniting Science and Technology
that's extremely important to our
societies extremely important to the
advance of both of those fields and this
Center will help continue to strengthen
MIT and these important fields no MIT of
course has had two already had an
enormous ly important role I just
counted up recently
mit is had 15 Nobel prizes on its
faculty many of them in science the
variety of wide variety of fields and in
science and training at
just such an outstanding place a country
and and and for the world
I want particularly emphasized the
importance of basic research the
importance of basic research and hence
of this new center and of the department
and also of MIT
it's a enormous payoff not only does it
help us and our understanding of our
universe our philosophy it's all our
thoughts but it's very important to also
go to our technology and to our economy
now in fact is one of your noble are
sort of Bob Solow who some time ago says
for every dollar of product sold by the
United States less than 1/10 e is
invested in research and development but
research has has much more than 1%
effect on the final product so
economically speaking investing more in
scientific research is sensible he was
one of the first to point out this one
the first economists point this out
strongly as I say not only does it help
our economy but it advances us
culturally and help us understand
philosophically what what we're all
about
now basic research gives us many
surprises we never know what's going to
be there and this is one of the problems
particularly with
for our politicians and financial people
no just watching sports basic research
you can't say what's gonna do that's
true you can't say exactly what it's
going to do but we know historical has
done wonderful things remarkable things
and they come about
suddenly surprisingly I just want to
mention two technological things you see
which is just like well the technology
coming out of basic science yes I was at
Bell Telephone laboratories when the
transistor was invented and my friends
were brought in Bardeen and sharpey in
brighton he was examining the resistance
of oxide on copper wires examining that
just studying it
he found a funny effect he couldn't
understand it now this is another
example of the importance of interaction
between different fields he went to his
friend john bardeen it was near by these
people together you see John body in the
series there what in the world is going
on and john bardeen looked at it and
thought about it said hey you've got
amplification you've got application
that your eyes oh no no no goodness say
so they've crushed them I'd lived in
Bill Shockley was another theorist was
right to the ER and he added some more
things to it and their cigars came about
to transition I just think about what
what effect the transistors had on us
just result for trying to study the
oxide properties of oxide on copper wire
of all things I might mention also the
laser now I was working on microwave
spectroscopy and that's giving a lot of
interesting science and getting a very
high rank very high spectral resolution
I wanted to get high on our resolution
but at higher frequencies because in
most better at higher frequencies and I
want
Oh down the wavelengths of millimeter or
shorter than millimetre down in the
infrared if possible I kept working on
it and thinking about it how in the
world can I do this
now there's another example of the
connection between science and
engineering I've been at Bell
Laboratories and had a good experience
with radar and engineering and feedback
oscillators and so on well not so many
physicists and of experience but also
regards visitors I knew some quantum
mechanics and I kept thinking about how
can we possibly get the shorter
wavelengths I can't build oscillators
that small we can't make them that small
with any power in them and so on
well of course molecules and atoms give
the exact frequencies but well you know
you have to heat them up to get high
intensity of radiation and I'm so hot
sitting on park benches we don't they
don't have described by a temperature we
can put them all in the higher state
well no this is required feedback of
course and oscillators and many many my
physicist friends didn't think it was
very practical but it wouldn't work very
well in fact the chairman of my
department said oh stop working on that
you know that's not gonna work you know
it's not gonna work it's a waste of time
wishing departments money well
unfortunately I had tenure and I could
say no I'm going to continue so it
worked we booked the first visit would
you call them as it was a first make it
operate in the microwave region which I
knew all about I couldn't make it work
there first and then I go into shorter
webmix
getting shot waiting so difficult and
without Charlotte those of them
we decided how to get on the short
wavelength and make the laser now in the
way that came along again
thought well okay that's a nice idea but
what good is it good after all well I
could foresee some things and even the
Bell Laboratories lawyers who we
suggested the patent they didn't see any
point I said well we know light has
never been used to communications we
don't think about different fattening
and so I talk so I'm going to go back to
them telling yes it can be used for
communication so they said ok if you
show us how to use music communication
we will Pat that you see the resistance
to new ideas we've got to have new ideas
and we our society has to be open to
them and that's what your people are
doing
that's what physics is doing basic
science new ideas things that break open
new things and the laser of courses are
multi-billion dollar business now people
said oh yes a nice idea but what good is
it what turns out to be in fact there
I'm just just delighted their useful
lives and now you may know one of the
first the very first gases is built
biology von here at MIT I came to my
teacher after that not the very first
gas laser and then we know the nonlinear
optics was another new field not in the
optics which also produces a lot of new
science and a lot of new technology well
now the United States has generally done
pretty well in science and technology
and the percent of our GDP which we
invest in it it was a little bit larger
than the percentage of Europe invest
it's not as large as what's been invest
a little bit larger than what Europe
invest
nevertheless we publish
somewhat more papers per person in the
United States than Europeans do and in
fact you want the numbers we play
published 809 papers per year per
million people whereas your publisher
Japan purposes 569 so we're doing
substantially better and the our
technological exports well that's the
technological exports of the share of a
total manufactured products United
States is about 29 percent lower than
Europe it's about 20 percent we're doing
we've been doing well on the other hand
recently we've been citing and I think
we must recognize that we've got to
speed up we've got to speed up Europe
Japan Europe particularly is getting he
got ahead of us
example the fractional ship share of
publications back about 15 years ago we
were publishing 38% in Europe and
publishing 32% now they're publishing
38% we're publishing 32% so we're going
downhill compared with Europe and
they're putting more into it and they
recognize the importance of it and we've
got to recognize in part we've been so
successful at it I think maybe a little
overconfident and I think most recognize
our public must recognize and our
politicians must recognize that we must
all recognize importance basic research
importance of the interaction of
different fields and here MIT is a great
place the interaction in different
fields and your department there's many
different many different sections but I
know science and engineering interact
here strongly and that's enormous ly
important what if those interactions and
borders of different fields importance
of basic research important it's new
discoveries unexpected discoveries and I
say as I say that's that's the problem
and we must emphasize that to the public
but must keep giving them examples and
so on we have to keep at it because it's
difficult to say well I don't see what's
going to come out of this know what we
know historically there are a lot of
wonderful things do come out of it and
they pay up pay off enormous me
enormously
and so we want to keep going no a lot of
also a lot of fascinating new fields and
fascinating fields and they're not all
new but fascinating fields in the
physics these days
cosmology just think cosmology cosmos
our philosophy our thinking and so on
one of my binges we're looking now again
you see surprises he was he did his
thesis with me looking for hydrogen in
the service bay she didn't find it I
went to Bell Labs he kept looking didn't
didn't find it what did he find
he found radiation from the Big Bang
discovered the origin of the universe of
all things no we know it had an origin
which surprised all physicists it
happened only 13 billion years ago the
universe was smaller grew up fantastic
not effects our philosophy and our
thinking and so this cosmology and
cosmology is just a fascinating field
now and then there's nanoscience when
the science of nanotechnology very big
in the very small this exciting field
biophysics is it is a great field now
and there's so many puzzles dark Nagas
the great majority of the matter and the
universal they don't know what in the
world it is 95% of the universe what is
it we can see some of its effects what
we can't what's most of this universe
mater and all kinds of new puzzles and
new things how did it begin the the
apparent discrepancy between quantum
mechanics and relativity matter forms on
it go still further and think about
free will how can we possibly have free
will there are all kinds of fascinating
and puzzling problems for us to finish
by thank you very much the greens and
the other people who've contributed to
this great establishment congratulations
to all of you for the new building and
very best wishes to MIT were personnel
the students and for the new scientific
insights
[Applause]
so I'm looking for Patrick Lee who is
there
so Patrick Lee from our condensed matter
theory group which we and particle
theory are delighted to have within
shouting distance will introduce Shirley
Jackson well I think many of you know
Shirley Jackson from her pictures which
MIT proudly displays along the infinite
corridor and it's a thrill for me today
to introduce you to the real person so
well Shirley of course was a real MIT
product she was undergraduate here and
also a graduate student she received her
PhD from the Center for Theoretical
Physics in particle Theory in 1973 and
after a few years she decided that she
wanted she wanted to change field and
become a condensed matter of theorist
known as solid-state physics in those
days right and so she went to Bell Labs
and I I happened to be working at Bell
Labs at the time and so soon after she
arrived we started collaborating and
became good friends since then and well
since Shirley has a history in both
particle physics and condensed matter
physics so it's very especially
appropriate for it address us today
because Wow part of one of the goals of
the Green Center is to bring these two
community communities together
so while Shirley was making a name for
herself in in research first in Bell
Labs and then at Rutgers another side of
her great talents began to emerge you
see even from these very early days and
I first met her she has shown that
special leadership quality that very
apparent
she won't hesitate to speak her mind on
issues that concerns are deeply be it
signs sign policy or social issues and
when she speaks she speaks with great
eloquence and conviction this talent did
not go unnoticed Shirley was appointed
by President Clinton
they had the nuclear regulatory in
agency in 1990 and five and she became
the president of the Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute in 1999 where
she's she still has that position today
ah throughout her distinguished career
Shirley has maintained a close tie with
MIT she served as a life member of the
MIT corporation and on our visiting
committee the physics department today
Shirley is recognized as a national
leader in science policy and education
she has received many reward Awards and
the most recent one is selection by the
National Science Board as a recipient of
the Vandiver Bush award that's another
MIT connection for a quote a lifetime of
achievement in science scientific
research education and senior
Statesman's like contribution to policy
public klausy unquote so let us welcome
Shirley Jackson she's gonna speak on us
to us and science the endless frontier
to continuing elephants of relevance of
Vannevar bush
well good morning I'm told that one is
known by the company one keeps and so to
be included on the panel of speakers is
a great honor now it is no secret that I
have a great attachment to MIT I did
receive all of my degrees here all two
of them
I spent the formative years of my young
adulthood here and as a life member of
the corporation the MIT corporation I
get to help Stewart the University today
so my reverence for MIT is is profound
and strong but most of all I revere the
transformational ideas which regularly
generate germinate within and around
this great place and the living presence
of these ideas in our lives in our
society in our nation and throughout our
world now may I say as we celebrate the
opening of the MIT Green Center for
physics these ideas cannot but better
germinate with the inspired design and
building adaptation achieved here I must
say when the new chair talked about the
idea of being around for 30 years I
remember that and creating a core Center
for the study of physics particularly
uniting condensed matter theory with
particle and nuclear Theory strengthens
the academic community and importantly
strengthens the physics department and
fosters a productive cross fertilization
of ideas
none that needless to say it is also
considerably more convenient for
students and faculty and easier to
administer now I'm delighted to be at
this dedication because Cecil green of
course was an MIT alumnus a life member
of the MIT corporation and great
benefactor jr. Johnson was an RPI
alumnus trustee and great benefactor he
was a co-founder with Cecil green and
Eugene McDermott of Texas Instruments
and he was the mayor of Dallas and
brought that town back together in the
aftermath of the assassination of
President John F Kennedy now having
received my doctorate in theoretical
elementary particle physics here now my
own career has led me as you've heard to
positions in government industrial
research and academia and eat in each of
the sectors in which I've had the
privilege to work I have found vision
and overall guidance in the work of a
distinguished MIT alumnus and professor
dr. Vannevar Bush now as you know his
seminal work science the endless
frontier has helped to shape science
policy in this country for more than six
decades and if we I believe continue to
adhere to its basic principles we will
see a continuation and a revitalization
of the unprecedented era of discovery
and innovation which our previous
speakers so eloquently speak to spoke to
and which has benefited our quality of
life and our national security but
importantly has enhanced life for people
around the globe now I said that the van
Busche was a an MIT alum but actually he
was a 19-13 graduate of Tufts University
but then he entered graduate school at
MIT and received his doctorate in
electrical engineering jointly from MIT
and you know the place up the street
called Harvard in nineteen nineteen
seventeen now during the last year of
World War one dr. Bush worked at the
National Research Council improving
techniques for detecting submarines and
while he was there he observed a lack of
coordination between civilian scientists
and the military and he began to
formulate his ideas about the
interrelationships among scientists in
the government academic and industry
sectors later he returned here to MIT
joining the Department of Electrical
Engineering as a professor where he was
from 1923 to 1932 becoming vice
president and Dean of engineering from
1932 through 1938
and while here he built a mechanical
analog computer designed to solve
differential equations with as many as
18 variables using wheel and disk
mechanisms to perform the integration
this was before the invention of the
discovery of the transistor effect in
the invention of other things now one of
his grad students was Claude Shannon and
another Frederick Terman who were was
instrumental in the genesis of Silicon
Valley now in 1939 dr. Bush assumed the
presidency of the Carnegie Institution
of Washington which supported intramural
research and awarded scientific research
grants to researchers at other places
and subsequently he held a series of
federal scientific research titles now
throughout much of the 19th century I
have to tell you federally sponsored
scientific research had been centered at
federal establishments such as the
Smithsonian Institution the US
Geological Survey and then a network of
Agricultural Experiment stations
established by the 1887 Hatch Act and
was charged with conducting research to
improve American agriculture now
scientists at universities on the other
hand were involved in advanced
scientific research funded primarily by
private donors philanthropic foundations
state legislatures and of course student
tuitions now during the period between
World Wars 1 & 2 the science community
expressed skepticism even some
antagonism toward the concept of federal
funding their experience of conducting
research within a university environment
fostered their allegiance to academic
freedom and they fear that government
funding might lead to government control
and the relinquishment of intellectual
freedom but singular events
shift paradigms and world war ii was
really a war of science and technology
in which military strategy
and technology developed in tandem and
with the wars onset dr. Bush convinced
President Franklin D Roosevelt that the
United States needed an all-out
mobilization for defense based on
collaborative scientific research among
the different sectors science was
mobilized under civilian control to
assist with strategy and to develop
technological measures to improve Allied
tactics and effectiveness scientists
evaluated military problems and
developed devices and weapons to resolve
these problems and to oppose enemy
tactics let me just tell you about one
because it says something actually about
the ingenuity of people in those days
before quantum science came to be the
German v1 or what was known as the buzz
bomb powered by an Argus pulse jet
terrorized and devastated London and
this first guided missile used a simple
autopilot which was really a weighted
pendulum to provide foreign act attitude
measurement to control pitch and it was
damped and stabilized by a gyro magnetic
compass and a countdown timer on the
nose driven by a vane anemometer was
said according to prevailing wind
conditions to reach zero upon arrival at
the target but these were effective as
area bombs and the characteristic
buzzing which ceased moments before
these bombs struck and exploded
terrorized and psychologically
demoralized the people in London now
allied countermeasures included
anti-aircraft fire but the v1 speed and
altitude were more than the rate of
Traverse of the standard British what
was called qf 3.7 inch mobile gun and
there are a number of other methods that
were only minimally effective but the
threat was reduced when more effective
measures were developed and these were
electronic aids for anti-aircraft guns
developed here at the MIT radiation
laboratory
or the rad lab as it was called which
was still in existence when I came as a
student and it was a division then of
what was called the National Defense
Research Committee under the leadership
of MIT President Karl Taylor Compton and
then Dean of engineering Avenue for Bush
and these devices were based on the
cavity magnetron radar-based automatic
gun laying and what the proximity fuze
in addition Bell Telephone laboratories
produced an anti-aircraft predictor fire
control system based on an analogue
computer now you're already beginning to
see the point I'm been trying to make
about this marriage of research the
universities industry and the government
and so as the war was drawing to a close
at the end of 1944 President Roosevelt
asked dr. Busch to evaluate the lessons
learned from the wartime mobilization of
scientific expertise and how they that
might be applied to peacetime pursuits
and so there were four advisory panels
convened by dr. Bush and in July of 1945
dr. Bush produced his strikingly
prescient report science the endless
frontier which he submitted to President
Truman since President Roosevelt had
died that April now read in its entirety
the report is comprehensible it sets
forth a National intellectual roadmap
focused on science but what most people
didn't realize in balance with other
national need for high ability in the
humanities the social sciences and
studies essential to national well-being
and it is a science policy model for
knowledge creation and application
encompassing the elements required for
innovation a blueprint for a new area of
science and the fundamental principles
of dr. Bush's report are simple first
that the results of scientific research
could be adapted readily to shifting
nationally
and could accelerate the pace of
innovation assisting not only in
national security but importantly in
medical advance economic growth quality
of life and overall societal benefit and
dr. towns has told you some of the
outcomes now science the endless
frontier set forth two important dicta
one posits that basic sciences perform
without thought of practical use to
derive fundamental understanding a
second offers that basic research
discoveries will be converted and can be
converted to become powerful drivers of
technological innovation now the reports
release made front-page headlines in the
New York Times now do you think that
would happen today it probably wouldn't
but the results that that report drove
have been dramatic and enduring in 1935
the federal government contributed only
about 0.35 percent of national income
for research and development by 1962
that investment had risen to more than
3.3 percent of national income an
increase of nearly ten orders of
magnitude and since the issuance of the
Bush report in 1945 a science policy
infrastructure has developed more or
less in line in with dr. Bush's concepts
at a science funding apparatus now
they've been several differing yet
identifiable periods you know in the
decades since then that have affected
science and have an reflect global
events and US interests and concerns the
first of course was the Cold War period
immediately after World War two and this
period was characterized by a robust
investment in defense space and nuclear
energy research and that is where the
genesis of high-energy physics really
came and a concomitant
vigorous support for students in science
and engineering and mathematics to
pursue studies and
higher education and beyond now second
period took place during the Great
Society program under president lyndon b
johnson but it wasn't a great period for
science because it was characterized by
a dip in support for basic research and
instead funding was focused largely on
social priorities and public sector
needs there was one area where research
support did increase and that was for
social and behavioral science now a
third period developed in the mid 1970s
when there was an increased interest in
national economic competitiveness and
the and that was because of japan
because there were questions and as to
whether the US could compete seriously
in engineering and manufacturing and
after the 1973 world oil crisis Japan
itself invested heavily in conservation
and in reducing oil dependence and at
the same time enhanced its productivity
advances in micro circuit circuitry and
semiconductors led to new growth
industries and consumer electronics and
computers
the net result expanded knowledge
intensive and service industries but us
concern over global competitiveness
however was short live when Japanese
economic growth slowed so today the
context of the Vannevar bush paradigm
has shifted somewhat and there is a
greater call for public accountability
greater less discretionary funding and a
narrower focus on short-term outcomes
federal investment in scientific
research has been shrinking driven by
concern over big government limits on
federal spending the federal deficit in
its growth as well as more confidence
and market driven private sector
research now the triple-a s of which I
was president in 2004 the American
Association for the Advancement of
science estimates that by over that
overall federal science research
spending has declined by half as a
percentage of GDP since
1970 now you know 50 years ago this week
I think in fact 50 years ago yesterday
we met the challenge of the Soviet
launch of Sputnik by employing elements
of dr. Busch's paradigm in much the same
way we did to win world war ii with the
breakup of the former Soviet Union
however there is no longer a Cold War
with imminent thermal nuclear standoff
there are other nuclear threats however
and the interesting thing is that the
outcome of wars fought since that time
have been determined less by opponents
advanced technology but as much by
cultural and other factors often beyond
the scope of science and technology and
so today 50 years after Sputnik we sit
with a need to focus on another great
global challenge energy security and
sustainability and I believe it is the
space race of this century we are in a
race against time as we were then
success requires multiple sector
collaboration as it did then but it
requires a base rooted in fundamental
research with no product in mind but
research always seeds new ideas leading
to yet unknown advances and research we
should not forget is important in its
own right but this will require
rejuvenation on a massive scale of the
university government industry
mobilization in basic research and
education which powered our efforts in
world war ii and beyond now there was a
recent law passed called the America
COMPETES Act that a number of different
groups worked to have enacted and I was
part of one of those actually two of
those one of them being a National
Academies panel whose report was
entitled rising above the Gathering
Storm and the legislation that was
signed into law supports a comprehensive
strategy to keep America innovative and
competitive and focuses on K through 12
through higher education
with a particular focus on energy now
I'm not going to spend the time to tell
you everything that it is about but it
does authorize strong increases for the
NSF as well as for other federal funding
agencies but the few the elements of the
Act really barely scratched the surface
but to the degree that appropriations
meet authorization levels it will begin
to refresh the compact to rejuvenate it
strengthen to develop more of you new
generations of scientists and engineers
and today dr. Busch's model of multi
sector collaboration is being realized
not only at the federal level but
increasingly in regional initiatives and
had state levels as well and of course I
have to tell you about one being the
university president last month
for example Rensselaer opened what we
call the computational Center for
nanotechnology innovations which results
from a 100 million dollar partnership
between and among IBM Rensselaer and New
York State and it makes possible a
supercomputer that ranks 7th in the
world and computational power and it's
the most powerful that any purely
university in the world and it will
generate more than a hundred teraflops
of computational power and large storage
now but it's only a tool but with its
sheer computational power and with the
ability to handle and manipulate massive
amounts of data this will support
computationally driven discovery and
innovation across a broad front
including in theoretical physics
computational biology and chemistry
engineering design climate change
modeling and more now our intent is to
link this platform with another unique
platform that we call the experimental
media and Performing Arts Center and
because of its unique physical spaces
and its technology impact will be a
technology enabled to creative arts
program
and platform but it's a research
platform as well because it will as an
umbrella for drawing the arts sciences
and Technology together it will allow
unique performances when married with
the computational power of the
supercomputer center and you say why
well it is our intent and I'm giving
talking to you about this because of
this link I've always found in
scientists especially physicists between
the science and culture it is our intent
to assemble the world's best orchestra
or at a more modest level the world's
best string quartet to play in one of
our spaces of one of our studios except
they will not all be in one room and to
create the real-time real presence
three-dimensional experience with an
audience in the room of dispersed
musicians playing simultaneously
together is its own research problem now
but why did I spend the time to talk to
you about this because this is about the
Green Centre for physics I talked to you
about it because the kinds of things
that people are trying to understand in
cognition and learning in perception in
artificial intelligence actually have
roots in the kind of thinking that and
the actual work that physicists do why
did I spend the time to talk about
doctor veneer of Bush at the symposium
celebrating the new Green Center for
physics well dr. Bush is understanding
that fundamental research powered by
multidisciplinary collaboration to do
great things is being played out here
today in the green Center as you draw
multiple sub disciplines of physics
together in one space and I can always
remember I said in this room for many
lectures by the way I always set where
the
yellow shirts at the middle seat of the
second row so I could look the professor
in the eye but he usually didn't pay
that much attention to me he was busy
writing his equations on the board but
the real message is that you know one is
always true to one's roots and drawing
disciplines together and sub disciplines
still I think is a paradigm for the
advance of science I also chose to do
this because Cecil green like dr. Bush
was a visionary because the success of
the company that he founded based on
originally instrumentation for oils
prospecting and drilling required in an
industrial framework the same multi
sector multidisciplinary approach we
talk so much today but let me just close
by telling you a little bit about my
physics experience here at MIT it was
unique and it allowed me even at an
early stage to do basic research as an
undergraduate as I'm sure many of you do
but even then I was a bit of a contrary
--an who reached into other fields in my
case material science in engineering to
combine the thinking in those arenas
with physics to do my bachelor's thesis
which was on tunneling density of states
in superconducting niobium titanium
alloys and I remember one of my physics
professors saying to me well you know
you know you've done pretty well here in
fact you've done well enough to go to
grad school here but but why solid-state
physics right you know if you wanted to
do you know nuclear physics or
elementary particle physics this would
be a great place for you well stupid me
I stayed here anyway and but I did
concentrate in particle Theory for my
PhD but I switched later to condense
matter theory when I had the chance of
course to work at Bell Labs with
the great physicists like Patrick Lee
and Morris rice who were my mentors when
I first went to Bell Labs but my physics
experience at MIT has enabled me to do
basic research in elementary particle
Theory at Fermilab and CERN to do
condensed matter theory at Bell Labs and
in those days they'd hire you if you
were smart enough even if you weren't
you know trained in condensed matter
physics and there I spent time studying
the electronic and optical properties of
two-dimensional systems starting with
charge density waves and layered
transition metal dye child car to nights
and moving on from there and I told a
good story about using studies that I
had started doing on the topological
properties of solutions to nonlinear
field theories in elementary particles
that they would be applicable to
something in condensed matter and it
turns out that in that problem I worked
on with Patrick and with Morris rice we
actually did discover a topological
structure that control the
thermodynamics of the charge density
wave system but also been able to do
science-based regulation and to help
develop national and global global
safety policy policy as chairman of the
US Nuclear Regulatory Commission which
likewise enabled me to form an
international nuclear regulators
association which drew together the
chief and heads of regulatory bodies in
Canada France Germany Japan Spain Sweden
the UK in the u.s. to work together to
try to improve the global safety Network
and to work with countries of the newly
independent states of the former Soviet
Union to improve their safety and safety
culture now I must confess the feeling a
little as though I have shadowed dr.
Bush all my life now we share the MIT
experience but my career path through my
positions and government industry
research in academia parallels
the essential elements of his life dr.
Bush became a life member of the MIT
corporation as am I and a regent of the
Smithsonian Institution as am i but the
real privilege for me was to receive the
event of her Bush medal last spring from
the National Science Foundation found
not National Science Board now I did not
know where my career would lead as I
left MIT at an uncertain time in fact
when I began graduate school most of us
were told we should kind of give it up
particularly in theoretical physics but
stupid me I stayed on and so I left MIT
armed with my bachelor's and PhD degrees
in physics and my life and career have
unfolded in ways that I could not have
predicted but it has been an exciting
journey to this point and that is the
real beauty of an MIT education of an
MIT physics education which reflects the
beauty of physics itself
[Applause]
if it's alright with the first two
speakers we actually have some time for
questions from the audience if any any
of these stimulating ideas have raised
them surely virtual
a unique way of educating students
because it actually challenges them you
know things are not textbook based even
in traditional courses and it certainly
allows students to explore open-ended
problems through research and I think
what one really does is one does not
create creativity one nurtures it and I
think that's what the education here is
all about it's very hard to convince
students that they should tell their
professors they're wrong but that's the
first step
other questions anybody want to raise a
point okay well I have a question
principally directed at Shirley but
anybody can answer this I think Shirley
you painted a picture of a time when
government interaction with basic
science was very optimistic and the
collaboration that grew out of that was
incredibly productive many of us feel
like in the present generation we live
in some kind of world that is a fantasy
creation where the government speaks
openly in political discussions about
science contradicting the basic laws of
science and ignoring the advice of good
scientists do you have any advice about
where that where we went wrong and how
to solve that problem
now you're asking me a political
question let me just say this that I
don't disagree with you and a lot of
scientists a lot of university
presidents a lot of people in public
policy are worried about that and that
is actually why I do spend a part of my
time but I think it's part of my job
because I'm educating scientists and
engineers as well to use the platform I
have to speak to the issues and I think
what we have to try to do is to educate
politicians to the fact that they
shouldn't kind of mess with science if
they want science to do what they
believe it should do because there's
been a disconnect between people's
understanding of the linkage of all the
things they think are important whether
it's defense or energy security whether
they're issues related to public health
pandemics whatever to our ability to let
science emanate and germinate ideas in
an unfettered way but it is not easy but
I think we just have to keep working at
it and and that's something I certainly
intended it any other questions
if not we've got a break for a little
over half an hour for their refreshments
outside it's a beautiful summer day
unfortunately and the possibility of
going up and walking around the Green
Center is still available will regather
a couple of minutes before 12:00 for our
second two speakers let's thank the
first two speakers
[Applause]